chairman we're good to go now
thank you hey good evening everyone uh
welcome to
rockford district council's remote
meeting of
the executive and welcome to anyone any
members of the public
watching this via the live stream
if i can take any apologies for absence
and having looked
around i think we're all here
item two can i ask sonya please to read
out the
names of any non-members attending
we have councillors mrs mason
newport stepchow
hoy yuanu wilkinson
and mrs shaw
thank you agenda item number three
can i take any declarations of interest
i'm not seeing any hands up right we
move into
agenda item four the re-mobilization of
leisure facilities
members as you know this is a special
meeting of the executive
that has been scheduled to consider this
single item of business
there is no provision for non-members to
submit questions to special meetings of
the executive
however given the level of interest in
this item
i have exceptionally admitted one
question
from each of the group leaders in
advance of the meeting
and the summary of the questions
received has been circulated to all
members
i will now deal with these questions
before opening
the debate on item four and i would like
to go through each of the questions and
then i will ask
councillor mike webb to respond
the first question which i will read out
is for from councillor
michael hoy the council has implemented
a review process over the financial
aspects
of the funding being given to fusion
lifestyle
however i have seen and had numerous
complaints on social media
in person and by email over the failure
of fusion
to tell customers what is happening
including
but not limited to problems with the 10
pound payment
people with wedding wedding bookings who
have not been able to contact anyone
and general queries on what is happening
what's measures are being implemented to
check on the customer service side of
the operation
to make sure our residents are dealt
with promptly
politely and fairly and if i can go over
to councillor mike
webb to respond to this question please
thank you councillor wilson and for
council ohio for your question as part
of the contract monitoring process
officers have raised the issue of
customer communication with fusion
leisure
fusion leisure will send the council a
weekly log of all complaints
comments and compliments received and
the outcome this will greatly assist
officers with the ongoing monitoring of
the service
as is always the case anyone that isn't
satisfied with fusion's response
can contact the council's leisure and
cultural services team
who will investigate their complaint
further
fusion will also monitor their social
media accounts
to ensure they pick up any complaints or
questions
raised through those channels they'll
also post an online visit
video of what visitors can expect from a
visit to one of the centers
with the restrictions that will be in
place and an example of this can
currently be viewed on the
whitton leisure center facebook page um
dated 31st of july
thank you councillor wilson thank you
councillor webb
the second question is from councillor
christine mason
and she asks the report gives emphasis
and detail on the preferred option yet
although it states that alternative
options were considered
there is no detail analysis or weight
given to alternative options
just a dismissive summary the report
effectively gives the preferred option
as the only option
and gives no alternative solutions for
debate or consideration
why were the alternative options not to
give an equal consideration
and present it to the committee over to
councillor mike webb please
thank you councillor and thank you
councillor mrs chris mrs mason
for the question the council values
its leisure facilities and the important
role that they play in the health and
well-being of residents
although this needs to be balanced and
considered with the impact that cobit 19
has had on the industry nationally
and the local impact on the increased
costs to manage these facilities
i set out in the report alternative
options include reopening
none some or all of the leisure
facilities
the estimated cost of operating each
site until march 2021 is also set out in
the report
the preferred option will see a phased
coveted security opening
of all the facilities bar the freight
house
since this is one of the buildings
proposed for early redevelopment as a
new community and civic
space within the council's asset
delivery programme
thank you councillor webb thank you very
much indeed
the third question is from councillor
james newport
and he asks what representation has the
council made
about the continued charging of
membership by fusion
to its members whilst the facilities
have been closed
thank you councillors and for councillor
newport for the question
during normal operation center members
can access a range of membership options
or use the facilities on a pay-and-play
basis
while the centers have been forced to
close centre members were offered a
no-charge
freeze option and a paid freeze option
the paid option came with associated
benefits including a range of online
workout
resources thank you
thank you councillor webb and the final
question is from
councillor mike wilkinson
i am concerned that this council is
looking to input nearly half a million
pounds
into the company managing the leisure
centers when this company has already
had
financial support during the covet 19
lockdown
and our district has numerous examples
of businesses who are in serious need of
financial support
this money is ruptured district
taxpayers money
and as such should be put to a full
debate by all members of the council
especially at a time when we hear time
and again
how short of money the council is and
that the financial gap is increasing
year on year
please can members be advised why it is
that when the council is clearly able to
convene an emergency meeting of the
executive
consideration was not given to an
emergency meeting of full council
instead so that all members could have
the opportunity to properly debate this
issue
and if consideration was given to an
extraordinary
council meeting why was this then
dismissed
thank you councillor woodson and
councillor wilkinson for the question
ordinarily there would be two meetings
one for the budget element of the
decision
which would be a matter for full council
and the discussion regarding the
contract
is a function reserved for the executive
the decision with regards to the
contract would be a key decision
requiring it to be placed on the key
decisions document
for it to be cleared for 28 days however
under the local authorities executive
arrangements
meetings and access to information
regulation 2012
regulation 10 allows for an exception to
the 28-day rule
if it is impractical to do so subject to
agreement from the chairman
of the review committee
the decision should not should be taken
as a matter of urgency
and not subject to calling because any
delay will seriously prejudice the
interest of the council
in that it will have an impact on the
delivery of the current leisure contract
specifically delaying the open reopening
of the facilities
to arrange two meetings would inevitably
delay the decision to reopen the
facilities
as this decision is considered to be
urgent there are mechanisms under
legislation and our constitution
to deal with such matters outside the
normal rules of procedure
our report explaining the reason for
taking an urgent budget decision
will be made to the next full council
meeting thank you
thank you councillor germany
if i can go over to the monitoring
officer chairman if i may
uh just to reinforce an now to council
webb's response
uh yes he's correct the contractual
masters of this kind is a function
reserved to the executive under the
local authorities functions and
responsibilities regulations
2000 uh and budgetary matters are for
full council to decide
um as councillor webb has pointed out
there is a mechanism in place to allow
the executive to take
urgent decisions it was not practical in
this case to call full council meeting
because of the significant impact of the
delay on the contract and the service
division
and uh we need to um i i just want to
reiterate the agreement the review
chairman has been sought and obtained as
required by
the uh requirements so for the sake of
clarity chairman if there was no urgency
for this decision to be taken
the ordinary route as council web has
pointed out would have been
to take the decision to council with
regards to the budget element and then
to yourselves members of the exec in
relation to the contractual matters
thank you chairman thank you very much
for
that further clarification to our
monitoring officer thank you
and i will now move to item four
which is headed re-mobilization of
leisure facilities
and that is to consider the report of
the assistant director
assets and commercial relating to the
reopening of leisure facilities
within the rochford district but before
i move to
councillor webb can i just
remind the members that there are two
exempt appendices to the report
if you need to make reference to either
of these apprentices
can you please indicate before speaking
as it will be
necessary to move a recommendation to
exclude the president and public first
so i go across to councillor mike webb
to
introduce the report please
thank you councillor wooten our leisure
facilities are very important to our
residents
and this paper sets out how we are
getting ready to reopen them following
the period of
enforced closure as a result of kovid19
let's not forget that before march
clements hall leisure center we're
seeing some fifty thousand visits per
month
and rayleigh leisure center some ten
thousand
these are key component parts of our
local economy and
supporting the health and wellbeing of
our residents
it is worth reminding ourselves that
kobe has delivered a significant
economic impact within the leisure
sector in the uk
both public and private the period of
enforced closure has resulted in revenue
lines collapsing
and while the industry has placed staff
and furlough to reduce staffing costs
many of the fixed costs to maintain the
facilities have remained
the pandemic is also projected to have a
longer-term impact on the industry
due to the requirements necessary to
ensure facilities are made copied 19
secure
and because of demand issues arising
from site users having confidence
in returning to use them
industry research shows activity levels
are only expected to rise to sixty
percent of
pre-covered levels by march 2021
with the best case scenario of up to 88
of customers returning
and less optimistic forecasts indicating
that this could be as low as only 40
this has resulted in a substantial
funding gap across the industry
not just in the district but nationwide
all the council's leisure sites closed
on 20th march 2020
as required by government legislation a
response to kovic 19.
the government announced the 9th of july
2020 that leisure centers would be able
to reopen from the 25th
of july 2020. industry guidance
accompanied this
setting out the adaptations that will be
required at leisure centers
ultimately limiting the offer across the
facilities and reducing the number of
users that could access
the centers this report sets out the
process undertaken by the council's
ledger operator to enable a phased
suitably adjusted covid19 secure
reopening
it also sets out the commercial
considerations that are required as a
result of the impact of covid19
during the transition period to march
2021 and potentially
beyond we know that government expects
leisure to be open
as do our residents especially the
swimmers and the schools that use the
swimming pool as well
so in preparation for reopening fusion
have provided the council with their
kovid 19 secure risk assessment
which has been viewed by the council's
health and safety officer and who
confirmed that they were following
government guidance
officers from the council's leisure and
cultural services team and environmental
health team
are carrying out site visits of both
leisure centres this week
officers from uh
leisure and cultural services team will
be revisiting sites directly before
reopening
and ongoing basis and a further visit by
environmental health will take place
once the sensors have reopened
all sites will be deep cleaned before
reopening
site visits have taken place elsewhere
for example in braintree and i can
confirm
that kovid secure measures are now in
place in that facility which is also run
by fusion
given the financial outlay this was not
an easy decision to make
but we want to protect our facilities
for our residents
and get them open as soon as possible
this work also allows us to support the
workforce in our district
these are not just numbers that
represent people's jobs
if the council did not provide the
requested subsidy for each site that it
wishes to reopen
fusion may argue that the current
contract is frustrated
in that case operation of the science
would revert to the council
it is con considered unviable for the
council to operate leisure services
directly in the short to medium term
due to a lack of available resources or
expertise within the council
[Music]
this would result in no leisure
facilities being available for our
residents
until the council was able to secure
another service provider
it is not considered likely that another
external leisure provider would be able
to take on a contract deliver
leisure services in the district at such
short notice
if financial support is agreed tonight
fusion's lifestyle's actual financial
performance will be reviewed monthly
with external consultants on a fully
open book basis
this will require fusion lifestyles
management accounts to be submitted at
setting up the detailed breakdown of
actual costs incurred
and income generated for each site
these will be compared to the baseline
projections above and any variations
interrogated by officers and advisors
to ensure that they can be reasonably
explained by fusion lifestyle
finally we will enter into negotiations
with fusion to agree a new commercial
arrangement
for the operation of the facilities
beyond march 2021
and report to the executive in december
2020 for approval
of that new arrangement
so to conclude i'm pleased to say that
we are looking to be able to reopen
clemental
both wet and dry side the mill
castle hall and rayleigh leisure center
and i can i give my thanks to the
officers particularly matt and naomi
who have been working incredibly hard
behind the scenes along with mark aldus
thank you councillor wilson thank you
councillor webb
and before i open it up to executive
questions can i
ask councillor simon smith to comment
please
thank you chairman um councillor webb
has given a
a very thorough um gracie of an awful
lot of detail
and work that has gone into the position
that we're in
today it's not been plain sailing
and um just for the sake of clarity
um all of the questions that
have been put um by the leaders of the
the the other groups that they were all
considered in various forms and various
details
it's it's not a comfortable place in
which we
find ourselves but we have to remember
that this is uh this is a situation that
is being
experienced in lots of industries and
lots of environments up and down the
country
um the the money that is quoted the
429 500 is a large sum of money without
a doubt
but we have to remember that for all our
grumbles and concerns about fusion and
and they are many and
and as mentioned um highlighted by the
questions that we've had already
we have to remember that the law has
changed the law says you can't have
uh yes said you can't have your swimming
pools open for a while
and now it says if you are going to open
them you can only have half as many
people in the pool um you've got to have
the distances issues about the
the catering it it's a a real
a real problem for fusion and i do
feel for them as a business uh and
and the situation that we've we've found
ourselves in
but businesses are starting to open up
our residents do have um
requirements and we're here to service
the
those requirements now as as
councillor webber said this isn't a
blank check that we
are writing this is independent
this is going to be subject to
independent review
on a monthly basis and
in terms of the mechanism of that review
uh
naomi can give you some detail
later on if if that's required
but just to um
highlight this problem ongoing we're
looking to open up
the the leisure the leisure facility
as best as fusion are able in compliance
with covid19 guidelines
right now we don't know how long those
guidelines are going to stay in place
we don't know whether we're going to
have better or worse
situations so we've got to look at the
the vision for how things are right
right now we're
very conscious of an ongoing financial
commitment
beyond um the end of this current
financial year
and as as councillor webb has said we
will look
to minimize or mitigate
or or completely remove that burden
from april and that will
involve more information coming to
council
in by december the this year
so that we can uh work out what is
what is going to happen what is the best
way forward
so i'm i'm i
i am supportive of this report but it's
with a
a heavy heart that we we spend this sort
of money
but it is money that through the good
and positive financial management of the
council
we find ourselves able to provide
so that the services that we provide to
our residents can be
maintained thank you chairman
thank you councillor smith and now i
will open up
uh questions from other members of the
executive and i believe councillor
cheryl rhode would like to come in thank
you chairman
um i do struggle with this chairman to
be honest
but i do have a couple of questions how
do we make sure that the money is ring
events for rochefort district council
sites
should this be agreed tonight we've been
asked a very big ask here
and we'd need to look after the
resident's interest as well as the
interest
of of the council itself do you want me
to ask two questions at a time
mike or would you prefer one at a time
my concerns also lie with the
cleanliness of
of certain sites especially that of
clemens hall
um it hasn't been that well kept in in
the past
and i've had numerous complaints from
residents
what measures are being taken to make
sure these sites are exceptionally clean
and i will make a point that the leader
and the deputy leader myself
will be visiting this site from time to
time thank you
thank you councillor i mean if i if i
start answering maybe
matt if you want to chip in as well
please feel free to do so
i mean obviously as i mentioned earlier
this isn't just an issue that's facing
us
in rochford south end council are
grappling with similar issues as
our braintree and indeed braintree
council have recently agreed 700 000
pounds to go towards the
opening of their leisure centers so
there's going to be close
scrutiny of the finances that we grant
to fusion
absolutely i don't know he's already
working in that until the open book
process will have a clear sight of all
the
the financial dealings and indeed um
what the traffic of people coming
through
all of our leisure services and in terms
of the cleanliness and we've already
um touched upon that but certainly
that's something that in the report is
very clearly outlined
the work that fusion have been been
doing to make our sites covered secure
um just just some of the
things that they're working on for
example will be hand sanitization
stations
entry and exit throughout the centers um
a one-way system
in the leisure centers um spray and blue
cloth
in the gym area for both users and staff
to wipe down services and equipment
gym equipment will be spaced out and
clearly marked with white tape
um changing rooms will be closed when
needed and only certain toilets
available
and stuff will be constantly cleaning
and wiping down high touch points
in addition to the to this i know that
matt hold white is speaking to senior
officers with infusion
to emphasize where there's been lapses
in the past where concerns have been
raised by members in the past
we do acknowledge that but actually i
think once you've
actually read the report the work that
fusion have been doing has been
incredible to bring these um premises up
so they also
they are covered secure and i have full
confidence in fusion going forward
matt and if you'd like to add to
anything that i've said
thank you councilwood chair chairman
through you um in terms of the
um the cleaning i think um councilweb's
covered in some detail
um just ready to add that i i hear and i
note to councillor rose's concerns
on the claim this issue um we have
raised it uh at
some length of detail with fusion we'll
continue to do so
we do have to say know those concerns we
will continue to address that with
fusion
uh carefully monitored going forward um
i'm more than happy to report back to uh
the portfolio holding other members
on progress once we're open as well i'm
not sure if they want to add anything
further to the open book process but
just to say that this is a
a recognized process in terms of
comparing
um budget with actuals and uh
identifying um
any variances in there and as council
have set out in his introduction
we will be working with um industry
recognized
experts to assist us with that approach
to analyze that
the open book process going forward
thank you jim
thank you for those responses if i can
move to
councillor ian ward thank you very much
chairman
um it's it's very interesting i
i have to go back to the questions that
uh were asked at the very very start
and i believe all of those questions um
actually we have all
how can i put it agonized over them
before
well these are these are ones that have
come up in discussions that we have had
coming into this meeting and you know i
fully understand them
and you know there's a few things that
obviously
are causing us all anxiety and i think
the most important one as far as i'm
concerned and has been echoed
is the resilience of fusion going
forward
and i think that's that's something that
has
not only occupied us but i'm sure it's
occupying
quite a few other councils up and down
the country
um but um you know when we're talking of
these options
uh you know i'm looking if i can just
refer
to page 4.5 and table one
and and the difference in 4.26
page 4.6 table 2. um you know
we're looking at least worst options
here
and you know there's an 83 000 pound
difference
between the two and and i think it would
be very very useful
uh if either simon or or mike
um would like to you know illuminate
everybody because this is this is an
important difference that we are
sort of having to choose the least worst
of some really horrible options to look
at and
i think that's very very important for
everybody to understand that
but going on to you know other things
with regard to our residents
in regards to the various things that
the government are trying to push and i
do
hope that where they have contributed
towards the arts
they will look to make support and
contributions towards
you know district and borough councils
who are having to
subsidize these costs at the moment
because
yeah it's a very very important factor
you know we have an obesity crisis
and it's one of the things which is the
comorbidities which is very severe where
we've got coronavirus
and it's very important to have fitness
outlets for people so
you know we're looking at the benefits
to our residents as well
so i i don't know if it's uh if i can
pass over
to both uh councillor mike webb and
councillor simon smith uh chairman
in regards to those two uh those two
items
council web if you'd like to go first
thank you councillor woodson
i think just to reiterate what council
awards said um this decision was not
arrived that easily
we debated it we agonized over it
we considered the various options um
because the amount of money that we are
talking about
is is a huge amount of money but
ultimately we felt the value to our
residents was greater
um and and the risks by not investing
here was our leisure centers would close
and once they are closed it will be much
harder to reopen them
ultimately i hope we've struck the right
balance here in terms of
reopening clementine not just the dry
side but the wet side
which as i've mentioned is used by not
just adult swimming schools
and swimming clubs but by a number of
local schools as well i thought that was
extremely important to reopen that
but also the mill providing a community
facility
within the rayleigh area but i hope that
will also be used by
residents within the wider district
certainly it's a fantastic facility and
i hope that that will
will come back um to to reach as many
people as possible
but certainly it was not an easy
decision to arrive at but i hope we
struck the right balance here
in terms of the proposals and in terms
of what we are
reopening for the benefit of our
residents thank you
thank you councillor webb i
wonder whether councillor daniel fd
wants to now come in with some questions
you're on youtube council fd from you
that's that's better isn't it near me
now um thank you chairman
got a couple of questions um page two
three point five
is so some cable pointing up there i'll
read from it um
he's proposed there for the council
negotiate new commercial contract with
effect from
81st of april 2021. it it does say that
in this report and it's something we're
looking at but
it doesn't mention anybody else i know
you're saying it's going to be difficult
for someone to take over from fuji from
fusion if
when we go to new procurement but
we need something in the background just
we don't know what's going to happen we
don't know what's going to happen in
fusion they might not want to do it
might get too expensive for us we need
something else there
so can i ask the officers to at least
look at
other people other leisure providers
for this if that if that can be done
um also
page 4.7 6.3
6.3 quick notes
so i'm asking about the alternatives
that might be available so
that needs to come back to us that we do
need that and we're looking at that in
december aren't we
so that was that the 4.8 8.3
yeah the grant funding definitely need
to look at that with our uh
officers i know you mentioned that and
also cheryl
um the
are we keeping a look at look an eye on
the reduced times i know we're going to
start off with reduced times but if
if the uh leisure centers become busier
which i hope they will do because i've
got every
faith infusion be able to keep them
clean and the government's going to be
going well
will they be looking at extending the
times because surely you'd want more
people
to go through the doors to extend the
times earlier and later like it is now
um i have looked at the facebook pages
on uh
billy ricky and stuff and they're all
saying how lovely and clean it is i hope
i'm sure they will keep that up and
that's about it oh yeah and what's what
does the dry side mean you mentioned the
dry side of quite a few times what does
that actually mean
is that other stuff is just as well as
gyms or is it just gyms
that's that's enough for me at the
moment so
it's quite a bit there councillor webb
do you want to
lead the responses thank you so um yeah
i made a note of your questions there
thank you council at fd so in terms of
question one
i think if we'd gone to the market and
followed our existing procurement
um framework we'll be struggling because
the market at the moment is just not
there
it's not just fusion that are struggling
this is a nationwide issue
um if we went out to the market i don't
think anyone would be would be bidding
for any leisure contracts at the moment
so we're doing the pragmatic thing which
is looking to delay
um going out to the market by a single
year but in that time we expect and we
hope that the leisure industry will
bounce back
what that means is that when we go out
to the market
our offer is much better and we could
then realistically expect to see i would
hope
at least three um providers looking to
win that contract
um obviously we can't shoehorn them in
it's an open
competitive pro process but i would
fully expect that once we've had that
additional year
then we would we would see a strong
competitive process between
i would hope at least three providers um
in terms of your second question
absolutely i would expect that funding
to be sought um
i would hope that we would be would be
pushing the central government for that
certainly where there was funding that
was given to the arts for example
i know there were rumors that there
would be a similar funding package going
to local authorities for leisure centres
i've not heard anything more about that
but i certainly think that's something
that may be through um councillor wilson
maybe we can be picking up again
and to put some more pressure on central
government for that potential funding
stream
in terms of your third question
i would expect that fusion leisure would
expand their opening times yes
absolutely
this is an initial offer but i'm i'm
confident that the public will come
through the doors again
and as they do those initial opening
times will be expanded
and finally in terms of your final
comment the dry side is simply the areas
that don't include the swimming pool
primarily the gyms but also a number of
the fitness classes as well
if matt's got anything to add to any of
those comments thank you matt
nothing uh thank you chairman could i
just quickly come back on the uh
we said the gyms and the fitness classes
have they got any sort of plan in place
when and if they were able to open stuff
like basketball and
badminton and squash and things like
that are they looking at that at all at
the moment or is it just concentrating
on
gyms and wet side
it's gyms initially because that's what
the guidance was
initially so some of the other sports
for example where ball's going to be
passed between competitors
that's been slightly later in terms of
opening but that'll be being looked at
as well
and would open when we are able and
ready to do so
okay thank you thank you councillor webb
and councillor fd uh moving on to
councillor williams
yeah thank you chairman um i have no
questions they've all been answered um
i've been reading the report i've read
it several times
i've anguished over this decision i
really have um
it really is a worry and it is the least
of the
i guess the least worst um way we can go
with this
fortunately we do have the reserves due
to mainly due to our
careful budgeting in the past and i
really think especially with the warm
weather has brought it home
how many people need to know how to swim
and it's very important that we open
the wet side as soon as possible we
don't want any any incidents in
around our coastline and chairman i will
fully support this recommendation
thank you thank you council williams
if i can come back to councillor smith
please
thank you chairman um i think council
web has covered
most of the points i just in terms of
the agonization of the
the the decision that we're we're coming
to i mean taking the freight the freight
house
for instance you know at the moment
even if we opened it there aren't
activities able
to to take part in that because the
council has been
well organized there there has been an
amount of progress
happening on the assets programme
through the
uh the lockdown period and
it it would seem like a foolish decision
to to open freight house at some stage
in the future when things are
relaxed immediately to start working on
how to relocate those
activities again because within 12
months or just over 12 months
we're likely to be um
you know effectively starting the
redevelopment of of that side
we do have facilities within the
district um
that are capable of reha rehousing or
relocating
most of the activities there so that
that that was one challenge
the other thing that we would have
started to be doing
right now anyway was to talk about the
new leisure contract
anyway um the leisure contract is a is a
is a big a big item for this council
it represents the biggest part of our
our assets
and the the finances around it are
really significant
um and and for us to decide
what goes into that uh that that
contract
takes a long time and and the
formalities of the legal
process are quite involved um
i think it were i think it was uh
i can't remember whether this council
ohio council newport talked about the
quality of
of communication from fusion at the
moment
you know since the last contract was
was let things have evolved around
social media
and so on there are thi and we've see
certainly seen some issues
with fusion around the quality of their
communication
they're things that we can specify
within it within a new contract
things we would be talking about now but
for us to consider taking on a new
contract
for april 21 um
i i just couldn't see that being a
sensible move
in any form the market the marketplace
is
is is chaotic at the moment to say it to
say the least
and a good number of activities as i
mentioned earlier within the
leisure industry simply can't take place
by
by law um we have made
representations i i i believe
um to to central government
um and there's certainly been some
representations
in mentioned in the media to central
government about further grants for this
industry
because it's it's not just a rockford
problem it's a national problem leisure
is
and it and it does need some support
so i'm i am i am happy to support this
this uh this report but it's it
it's not a happy recommendation it's
it's the best
solution and the most pragmatic solution
to support our residents
and the councils in a position to do it
thank you
thank you councillor smith um i don't
see
any other hands um
in which case i would like to add
a few comments and ask a few questions
throughout this report there is
reference to the word preferred
in itself no problem with that word but
a bit like counselor williams i read it
i kept on reading it
and i looked at it and i thought that
implies that we are comfortable
with what we are doing in the sense it
is a preferred option
it is a choice of the least worst option
um
in terms of the financial bailout that
we're talking about
and i would like to propose certainly in
the decisions being recommended
that we replace the word preferred with
the word
selected it is the selected option
and that was the um
consideration uh there were a multitude
of
options uh but we did
as other members have said agonize over
the least worst and we are in a position
where we are damned if we do
and we are damned if we do not it is as
simple as that
but i believe that at the heart of
everything we do
is our residents and health well-being
fitness
and leisure is an element of life
that is being missed by many in our
district
we mustn't overlook the fact that to
keep these premises
closed was also a very costly
option and obviously we were looking at
that as a possibility
i've heard the concerns over fusion
if ever there was going to be
microscopic forensic
testing of them over the next few months
that is coming
because i believe on various fronts we
need to make sure
that our money is being spent wisely
appropriately and in the best interest
to perpetuate the provision for for
leisure facilities within the rockford
district
i certainly want there to be no reliance
and in fact
no doubt by anyone that there will be
continued funding
beyond april 21 when we move into our
new financial year
it is by no means a given
it will be based on what we see over the
next few months
and we will continue to be supportive if
fusion
demonstrate to us that they are doing
the best
to continue with leisure services in a
top-rate world-class standard within
rockford district
and i have to say the early reports in
other districts
are positive but i want there to be no
doubt
that we will be having a microscopic
view of
what is going on and i will be the
biggest mystery shopper that walks
around our various
sites to see what is going on
and i know that other members will be
doing exactly the same
if i can come back to the reports please
i'd like to ask the section 151 officer
please
when we talk about the support that has
been given to us from central government
we're talking about 1.011 million
have we any idea please naomi what
element of funding we will still have
available
to offset the um the provision within
the council itself
that's my first question
if i turn to 4.10
i have to say that i'm delighted that
officers and the portfolio holder
recognized the need that we need to have
independent professional scrutiny and
that is mentioned in 4.10
and 5.8 so thank you very much indeed
so the wider member population
i would like to reassure you that we
will be
reporting back and providing an update
on progress
regularly the next opportunity will be
in
october at the council meeting when i
provide a
report on progress since it opened
and i have to endorse what counselor
webb said
and councillor smith there are a number
of unknowns
which frankly are out of our control and
certainly out of fusion's
control so that is really all i wanted
to say but i do have that one
question um to our
section 151 officer if that is possible
because it is coupled
the the bailout which is significant
as i see it is potentially three
components it is the residual
of any government funding we've received
so far
it is the potential funding that we may
receive from
central government towards leisure any
provision that the government announced
nationally
and of course um supported from our own
reserves i wonder whether you can just
help me on that please naomi
thank you thank you chair um yeah so
um we have um recently submitted some
revised estimates of the financial
pressures
um back to central government and i will
be circulating
a note to all members in the next
day or so and so i won't elaborate into
um in great detail in terms of all of
those but
um as per previous returns um we are
anticipating that the
total pressures facing the council this
financial year
um at the moment are likely to exceed
the amount of
government grant funding that we have
been um
given already which as you've already
rightly said is just over
one million and there are obviously a
number of
um assumptions within within those
projections and most notably the this
most
um significant other pressure we've been
reporting so far is the loss of car
parking income which we are obviously
keeping a close eye on as well
um that was in the region of sort of 700
to 750
000 pounds of income that we're
projecting to lose having said that
there there is a um a further um
provision that government have set out
at a high level although they haven't
yet issued any detail
that is committing to um uh
um subsidize some of those um income
losses
so um we are expecting that on in
addition to the one million pounds of
grant funding that we've already been
given we are expecting to be able to
recoup some of those
income losses separately as well but
because government hasn't actually
issued any of the detail of that yet
i'm not in a position to say exactly
what level of financial support will be
offered
for that um so um
yeah it's difficult to give a precise
sort of number to you at this stage but
as i said
as we have said previously the total
financial pressures we
are expecting will exceed one one
million pounds and i will be issuing
a further detailed note setting out um
all of those financial pressures um in
the next
day or so and as other councils have
alluded to we have got
the option of some earmarked reserves
which we can
draw on um as a last resort during the
financial year
um were the government funding um not to
be sufficient to meet all of our
financial pressures but
it is still quite early in a stage in a
financial year
and as i've said we've had to make a
number of assumptions and estimates
within our projections so
um we will be closely monitoring that as
the year progresses as well
i hope that answers your question thank
you very much naomi
i've got some other people wishing to
come in and i'll come to other members
in a moment
but i will be asking subject to
agreement with my
two amendments on the
decisions um my first
amendment will be on 1.1 i would like to
see the word
preferred replaced with the word
selected and my other
suggested amendment is on 1.3
we're on the fourth line beyond the 2020
stroke 21 and i would like to insert the
words
hopefully with non-reliance on rdc
subsidy shaman if i can come in there
i'm happy to second both of those
amendments
thank you chairman if i just may come in
um just um for ease of proceedings you
have made
um amendments to two separate
recommendations
and i would suggest that you uh
uh amend each recommendation in turn
so you would um it's been say for
example
uh council row has seconded your you'll
recommend your amendments to those
recommendations
so for the first recommendation i can
ask
um sonia to read out the new wording for
you
and you would you should proceed to a
debate on whether that amendment is
accepted if it's accepted then you can
then go to the vote to
um uh to accept that as a new
substantive motion and
and vote that as the new recommendation
thank you chair thank you very much for
that intervention
i don't see any other hands um
so i will uh ask
sonya if i may to read out the amended
recommendation so that we can debate
that
sonia you're mute you're on mute
uh i'm not uh can you not hear me can
now
yeah okay thank you so um
my understanding is that uh in terms of
1.1
it should now read that following
consultation with the portfolio holder
for community
and the portfolio holder for finance the
selected option
set out in paragraph five of this report
for the reopening of leisure facilities
within the district
be approved and
do you want me to read at 1.3
chairman i think chairman i think we
should take each recommendation in turn
i think ignite with your your
recommendation
angela and first of all is
anyone wishing to speak against that
suggestion that recommendation
i don't see any hands so
i believe we need to vote on that as a
uh now substantive recommend
recommendation you take a vote as to the
amendment being
accepted whether it's accepted so you
take a vote on your
the new um on the word selected being
inserted instead of using the word
preferred
okay and uh i was going to go to sonia
to read out the role
of names please thank you um
so members if you could uh if you could
just uh if you want to recorded vote if
you
if you could indicate that sonia can i
just interrupt you for a moment you're
very very faint
okay uh i will i will speak up chairman
is that better
that's much better okay so um
can i ask you please to indicate if you
would like a recorded vote
otherwise um can you please uh vote
either for or against uh the the
amendment to the to the motion
or if you'd like to abstain so
councillor
fd no recorded vote and for the
amendment please
thank you counselor mrs rowe
thank you sonya no and four please
counselor smith no recorded vote and
four
thank you council award
uh sonia sorry it's no m4
thank you councillor webb no recorded
vote and four
thank you thank you councillor williams
thank you very much no n4 please
thank you and councillor no and four
that's unanimous chairman thank you very
much indeed
sonia if we can move on to the
recommendation 1.2 and i will read it
out
that additional budget of up to 400.
sorry we need to vote on the second
just to be clear on the procedure you
you can
um now that that amendment has been
accepted you can um
take a vote on the new substantive
motion or you
if you wish to do so you can deal with
all the amendments first and then we'll
go back to voting on the new substantive
motions
okay all right shall we take uh my
proposal then on 1.3
i think that's what the monitoring
officer is suggesting that we look at
1.3
in terms of an amendment and uh just to
remind sonja
that i wish to propose that we
insert after 2020
stroke 21 on the fourth line
with the words hopefully with
non-reliance
on rdc subsidy
right so just to uh to read out the
proposed amendment then to that
uh recommendation that in consultation
with the portfolio holder for community
and portfolio holder for finance
the assistant director commercial and
assets
initiates negotiations with fusion
lifestyle
to agree a new commercial arrangement
for the operation of the facilities
beyond the 2020-21 financial year
hopefully with non-reliance on rdc
subsidy and brings a report to the
executive in december 2020
setting out the terms of the proposed
agreement
thank you sonya and uh i don't see any
hands is there anyone that wishes to
speak chairman can i just um
ask for your um counselor mrs rowe
whether she
had agreed to second that amendment
yes thank you thank you
i don't see any hands on the uh
asking to speak um so in that case
um can we take sonia
that uh suggested amendment
uh councillor smith um chairman yeah
i'm not not wishing to change your
uh motion um
but just to ensure that members of a
fully wary
executive forms um i believe
2nd of december and with the publication
for um
deadlines that are required obviously
that's going to take us back into
november then there's the time to
actually do the discussion
um i don't want to change anything but i
think members just need to be aware of
the
for i've just put as the fragility of
that date
and the ambition that your amendment
has thank you thank you councillor smith
um that is why i really wanted to insert
the word
hopefully because i think that gives the
opportunity
for flexibility in the light of superb
performance
by the operator because i want real
focus to be placed
on uh you know performance over the next
few months but i did
feel that hopefully or to
give that flexibility that you indeed
make the point on
i don't see any other hands so in terms
of that proposed amendment could i ask
you sonya to go through the roll call
again
of course so uh councillor fd
no record he's voting for the amendment
thank you
mrs rowe thank you sonya no
and for councillor smith
no recorded vote and four thank you
council award thank you sonia it's known
for
councilweb
that's unanimous for chairman
so i believe that now
unless there are any other amendments
that are being proposed
i think that enables us to take
all the decisions on the block unless
anyone disagrees or wants to take them
separately
chairman i've just got a question
yeah we've just let me go back to
the word in with uh 3.5 the second bit i
didn't actually read out
the early termination the flexibility
to manage relationships with fusion
lifestyle
what notice do we what knows would that
be written into the contract what notes
we're going to give or we've got any
idea what notice we
might want to give or am i being a
little bit too
matt really we'll answer that one the
chairman if i may i i think we'll
probably get into quite detailed
discussions
of the contract negotiation wouldn't
want to give any uh commercial
information away at this time but um
something i can discuss through the
portfolio holder
okay thank you thank you matt thank you
councillor fd
um right
cam are we in a position to now take all
recommendations
subject to those amendments that we've
agreed uh we can we now take them
on the block unless i see any hands i
take it that
um now if i may i just wanted to point
out that the word preferred is also used
in recommendation 1.2
given that you wanted to change it in
the first one you might also want to
change it in the second
uh thank you naomi uh i hadn't actually
picked that yes you're absolutely right
and i'd even underlined it i missed it
in the uh
um well i think we need to go through
on 1.2 please and uh i'm making a
proposal uh that we replaced the word in
1.2
we've selected do i have a second one
i'm happy to second that chairman
okay and have we got anyone wishing to
speak before i ask sonya to take it to
the uh
the the call now i can't send you names
sonia would you be kind enough to go
through the list of us
right so councillor fd please no we call
you voting for the amendment thank you
councillor mrs rowe thank you so much no
and for
councillor smith no recorded vote and
four
council award thank you sonya no one for
making webb thank you sonya no i'm four
councillor williams it's sonia no n4
councillor no and four
again that's unanimous chairman four
thank you very much and a particular
thank you to our section 151 officer for
uh pointing that out because that was an
important important
change there thank you can i come
in as well yes we're seeing as we're
looking at preferred
um we should go then to section of 4.5
item 5 heading preferred option
that should be changed i would suggest a
selected option
in terms of the report there are a
number of places that the word
uh preferred appear um
i certainly take your point i i
particularly would like the um
recommendations changed um but the
report is actually the report
um i i think it would uh
whilst i note your comment i think it
would be a bit onerous to start changing
a report which we've actually debated
we've just modified
the the recommendations
is that a correct view angela
cameron i said yes i mean i mean um you
you made a
um an amendment to the motion and you
have set out
your reasons why you prefer sorry not
use the word prefer
why you're using the word select instead
of prefer um
it is on it is i mean the report is
written as it is written
and you have made your point as to why
you
would like to use the word select
instead
thank you very much thank you um
right i think we can now
go to taking all the recommendations
on block as they now
stand so um sonia
what are you proposing to do read every
recommendation out
i ca i can do so if members would like
no not necessarily believe it or not
we've read these recommendations so many
times
yep okay now i'm i'm happy with that if
members are
happy with that and in that case we go
straight to the uh the roll call please
counselor fd murray called his vote and
for the recommendations
thank you councillor mrs rowe thank you
sonya
no and a very reluctant for
councillor smith no recorded vote and
for the recommendations
yes thank you sonya it's known for
thank you webb thank you sonia no and
four thank you councillor williams
thank you sonia not an easy decision but
that's again no and four
thank you thank you and councillor
and that's a no and for for me
that's unanimous um for chairman
thank you very much indeed sonia and
just before i close the meeting can i
thank everyone for their contributions
officers for the work that you've
actually put in to bring all this
together
and all member colleagues and
thank you for a very good debate i was
very keen
that we did debate it which is exactly
what we've done
thank you very much indeed everyone and
with that i will close
this executive meeting thank you very
much indeed thank you chairman
thank you chairman thank you